to discuss that as well as the then
firing of tom herman
they win a ball game texas is back you
know he's not back
tom herman bruce feldman of the athletic
and fox sports happy new to you bruce
happy new year rich good to be honest to
be had with
you right here let's get right into
texas what happened there
with tom herman bruce you know
rich right around uh three weeks ago
the idea of texas put out a statement
that
was really carefully worded very cryptic
i remember we talked about it on our
show um
the day it came out where a lot of
people were reading it
into it like it was like this vote of
confidence that tom herman was gonna be
the guy who's gonna
remain our coach and you know it was
worth noting at the time
that statement came out four days before
national signing day so it was basically
like to try to
do the best they could to kind of keep
recruiting
uh on track as best they could but then
after uh you know they had a nice bowl
win against
you know an undermanned underwhelming
colorado team
but i don't think that gave anybody else
the feeling inside texas
that they felt any more confident that
tom herman
was going to get it done there and so
they ripped the band-aid off
and you know look i i we had reported
this
probably um i want to say in like early
december
that texas brass had made the decision
to move on from tom herman
and really what that seemed to look
focus focusing on okay
it's urban meyer or bus well
urban meyer obviously didn't want that
job and didn't want to go back to
college football
but the mindset of tom herman
it's like the players were you know from
what i had heard were over him
they just didn't feel the connection to
him they didn't buy
into him at that point and at that point
it was like okay what are we doing here
we're going to keep spinning our wheels
they have made the determination
uh texas had been vetting steve
sarkeesian felt very comfortable with
where sarkeesian is at right now
and he's had obviously a great couple of
years in tuscaloosa
and they they moved fast you wouldn't
have spent the money they spent which is
15 million dollars for some tom herman
to get rid of them
if you didn't have somebody lined up
which they did okay
so um it seems that the
position of coordinating the offense for
alabama more often than not is a career
rehabilitator
see kiff and comm elaine and now
sarkeesian
comma steve i couldn't help but notice
your tweet today about who might be next
for that job bruce feldman yeah i mean
look
these are two former you know recently
fired nfl head coaches
bill o'brien for formerly the texans and
adam gates of the jets
and if you're a jets fan or somebody
like that you're probably going adam
gase
right uh look adam gase was a student
assistant when nick saban was in the big
ten at michigan state
that's where he got to know him nick
saban brought him as a graduate
assistant to lsu
and remember like an oc a few years ago
who did it well for saban and tuscaloosa
with brian dayball who by the way wasn't
a
was a grad assistant at michigan state
of saban way back then
um so those are two of the names i heard
saban's really considering and obviously
the connection to
bill o'brien is obviously bill o'brien
and the
belichick protege and obviously saban
and he are very
close so we'll see you know what
direction nick saban wants to go i mean
as people have said you know he has
rehabilitated the images of
of many many coaches so you know it's
like
you know people will roll their eyes but
you know i'm not sure anybody
thought you know five years ago that
steve sarkeesian was going to be one of
the hottest names in coaching
and he is or you know he thought some of
the things that have happened maybe
i don't think they thought lane kicking
would would end up where he is i don't
think they thought mike waxy would get a
big 10 job
so it's the the wonders of nick saban
well
a co-offensive coordinator and wide
receivers coach there moved to michigan
to be the offensive coordinator and josh
gaddis and that
really hasn't worked out yet what is
going on with my alma mater
a contact contract extension is sitting
there for jim harbaugh to sign i'm not
familiar with the terms
i'm wondering if the terms are not to
jim's complete liking
otherwise his john hancock would be on
it right now unless
he's hoping that uh he's justin
herbert's next head coach or sam darnold
or justin fields next head coach
with the jets what is going on with my
alma mater and jim hart jim harbaugh who
could
be the coach still there tomorrow with a
new extension or something else what's
going on
with this rich my understanding from
talking to sources
is and we've reported this over the
weekend
that they have a contract extension
through 2026
that he feels pretty good about from
what i've been told now
if the charger said hey we'd love to
have you and
you could get to coach justin herbert i
think that would be
very very tempting for him i don't know
how it wouldn't but
if that doesn't happen um i i think
you know from everything i had heard
that they felt like
he was going to be coming back to
michigan so
i mean i guess this is this is going to
be interesting to see
it's not a shock that the the chargers
job has come open
i mean it's not a shock that some of
these other jobs are open the question
is
you know is jim harbaugh stop now where
was
it's interesting because one of the
people who seem to have done really well
on my charger staff is pep hamilton
right he's done a good job
with justin herbert and i and pat
hamilton as you all know
yep spent a lot of time around jim
harbaugh
both at stanford and then again at
michigan
so i don't know this would be
interesting i i mean
i don't i don't uh it's hard to
jim harbaugh is pretty unpredictable in
the way
he's operating he's never been anywhere
as a coaching staff as long as he's been
at michigan right now
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
moving parts in this from what i'm told
bruce feldman the athletic and fox
sports here on the rich eisen show
what about matt campbell at iowa state
or pat fitzgerald at northwestern are
they going to get
uh maybe a matt rule type knock on the
door from the nfl
what do you think on that front i think
they will i think
fitz is probably more likely to engage
it i think a little i'm not saying he's
going to leave and i'm not saying
right matt rule wouldn't consider it i'm
sorry matt campbell wouldn't consider it
but i
just the read that i have is
i'd always heard pitcho wouldn't even
think of leaving
northwestern unless he was going to be
the bearer's head coach because he just
has so many in his family have so many
ties
to that area um but
he does have a he's going to have a new
aed jim phillips who is a great aed at
northwestern is now the commissioner of
the acc
so some of the things have changed a
little bit uh i don't know
if if he would ultimately end up
end up feeling comfortable to leave he
knows he's got a good situation there
he loves the place his family loves it
there it's just the question is what
could somebody put in front of him that
can make
could could pull him away um
you know with matt campbell i think it's
it's probably a little different
situation
where he's at i think he's continued to
build at iowa state
i think he's probably very interested in
saying okay we've taken this next big
step
what can we do now you know from from
here
and so i don't know i i could see him
definitely getting
you know he a lot of people are very
intrigued by him
you know wouldn't shock me if like if
jacksonville
doesn't end up with irma meyer they end
up you know looking at him and trying to
to get him but i don't you know
matt's a tougher one to read he wasn't a
guy who i think was going to leave
iowa state to go to texas i don't know
exactly how
if he feels like he's not done yet at
iowa state
that's the thing i i feel like he's
taken big steps from a program that was
completely
on the floor and built it does he want
to leave her does he want to see if he
can
you know turn it into a playoff team i
mean he's done some amazing work there i
just don't know if he's
ready to be ready to jump at this point
bruce feldman here on the rich eisen
show and you just mentioned how
matt campbell might want to have iowa
state sticker
stick around there to see if he can turn
him into a playoff team but
what we just saw play out over the last
few weeks
how how in the world if you're not a
blue blood
how in the world do you make the final
four right i mean like
cincinnati sits back there takes georgia
to the limit
and watches what we saw uh
happen to notre dame for instance they
might have been roadkill or a speed bump
as well
uh for alabama but it's just it
it was just so deflating that we saw
this selection process play out the way
that it did
texas a m being another one but they're
kind of a blue blood
anyway in the sec you know i
it just seems to me that that this year
um showed why we either need eight teams
or a complete
uh admission that if you're not a blue
blood and you don't go undefeated see
you later we don't care
right yeah i think it's a complete the
cfp
is a farce rich i mean everything you
said there
there is cincinnati is evident
that you have no shot
to to get in under this system you just
don't because they were gonna get capped
wherever i mean
florida you know is stumbling all over
itself down the season and they're
barely
budging you know like they you know like
losing traction in the rankings it's
like these glass ceilings that are
placed
on these group of five programs
cincinnati is
every bit as good as notre dame no doubt
this year and you know they
you know again they went toe to toe with
georgia in basically what
you know george's in atlanta and it was
a game where yeah georgia was down
players but by the way
cincinnati was down their two best
defensive players um you know two
you know all-american caliber defensive
backs and
they had georgia on the ropes it's like
you know they were down you know a bunch
of linemen
i just think that it shows how good they
are but it also shows how ridiculous
the system we have is i think they need
to go to eight
i think they end up they will go to
eight teams because they know there'll
be more money there
and they chase the money and i think
they also
will feel so much pressure that they
have to have a way
to have more uh more of an
actual pipeline for inclusion because
right now there isn't
any and for them to try to tell people
that there is or hey there's an
eye test i mean they're all full of it
you know it's not
i mean let's call it what it is and so
does that mean that if cincinnati was in
an 18 playoff that they would be able to
to beat alabama you know probably not
but let's let's see it right not have
this facade where
they're basically an fcs probe you know
looks like there's
the level between the fcs and the fbs is
this group of five which
you know either let them in or or
don't use them for fodder to dress up
the rest of the sport when it's
convenient for you
bruce feldman here on the rich eisen
show and while we're on that subject
the other uh question way back
um in the summer whether there's going
to be a season in the big tent saying
we're having one and then here's a
schedule and then by the way nothing
and then nebraska parents and ohio state
alums and very important ohio state
individuals behind the scenes
forcing the big ten's hand putting them
out on the field and you know the health
and safety of the players
uh we will see down the road what
happened by playing this season
all that said let's place aside the
health the
fact that the big ten in ohio state was
uh
adamant in ohio state getting the big
ten to get back on the field that paid
off
that paid off big time over the new
year's weekend
i mean what a performance that was just
an absolute dynamite performance by
the ohio state taking on alabama and
i'll be tuned in i'll tell you that
that's a big matchup right there bruce
big time
yeah i i think things got even more
interesting because of
look i thought to justin fields i mean
he was fantastic
it was what was amazing to me was if you
told me this was going to happen like
after their third game
that this was going to be it i'd be like
yeah i could see it because
he had been he had like completed almost
90
of his passes in the first three games
but you saw him
struggle and had some pair three picks
against indiana and then you saw him
look like he lost some confidence
against northwestern now
trey sermon ran wild in that game but
and then granted they did not have chris
salave who's their
best receiver but this is a really
talented group of receivers right and so
offensively i think they can hang with
alabama the issue is going to be on the
other side of the ball
right you know like i don't
know if their secondary can hold up like
alabama
is way better on the offensive line than
clemson is
and right now the receiving core that
clemson puts out there is not
what what alabama has and
i just think that this presents a
different test but if justin fields is
going to play like he did the other
night
and they're going to come out with a big
chip on their shoulder because they
still have it and they have confidence
um i think this was a really good thing
for
for for the playoff in that regard of
what we're gonna have because never mind
just that ohio state is huge
you know tv brand and and they have a
huge fan base that's gonna tune in but i
just think
you know there is a little bit of
there's a newness at least something a
little like what you had with lsu that
has got people intrigued where it's just
not and this is no disrespect to trevor
lawrence who's handled everything
you know i think in a first-class way
but i just think
there's something about ohio state
against alabama that
is very interesting to people that the
other game
maybe just is going to be met with the
shoulder shrug people like die hard
college football fans are going to tune
in but now i think it's just
risen like three levels bruce feldman uh
have you done your last shows do you
think with urban meyer
you think he goes to the jacksonville
jaguars what do you think
that's a good question because i think
we may have a show this weekend um
you know i don't know my my feeling was
gonna be it was gonna be
60 40 he stays i don't know coaches have
a hard time to
to say to say they're done coaching
and get tempted and he's seen trevor
lawrence up close in person he got to
see him last year in the playoff and was
wowed by him but i don't know
i mean you know the idea of him going
into
you know as you know winning in the nfl
is really
really hard bill belichick's the
greatest football coach in the history
of the sport
and he just had a losing season you know
urban meyer does not handle
losing well at all it guts him and i
think
the idea of that model when you're you
know you're not allowed to have 25
first-round picks it doesn't
it's the recruiting is not the same you
know and it's like
you know how would he handle losing
consistently not saying he's going to go
on 16 but there's a probably good chance
that whatever job he gets they may be
looking at four and 12.
i mean how would that guy deal with that
i don't know and i think those are
things that he's thinking
and to be honest which i really think
urban may think they may be tempted on
one day of the week and the next day
maybe i'm not doing that you know and
just or whatever
and so i'm interested to see what he's
going to decide
um you know i know it's definitely on
his radar and that part's real
i just don't know what he's ultimately
gonna gonna make the
decision in his heart that he thinks is
really the best move for him
is he really curious to say how would
this work for me in the nfl
i gotta find out if he does then if he
really come to that decision
then you know i could see him in
jacksonville bruce thanks for the time
happy new year let's chat uh before and
then after the national championship
game let's
stay in touch thanks happy new year you
too that's bruce feldman here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here